Let's take a quick look of how
to set your scanner settings.
That is, to set it
for a particular dpi.
So what you do is you
first take a preview.
At least on my scanner, this
is the software that I see.
Yours might be different,
but the idea is the same.
So we get a preview.
This is what my
screen looks like.
And what I decided to do is scan
only this particular portion
to get final images of
this particular device.
So I did that.
That's how it looks.
And when I press
scan, I am asked
whether I want to save it.
And I did intend to
save it at 72 dpi.
That's the first scan
that I decided to take.
And then I went through a
whole series of various scans.
And let's look at
them all together.
The various scans were 72 dpi;
300; 2,400; up to 6,400 dpi.
And let's see the difference.
Here it is slightly
enlarged, sort
of trying to keep the same
visuals for you to compare.
I'm starting to see that
the 72 dpi is definitely
losing clarity.
The others look OK.
And as we increase
the images more so,
we're starting to see
this one breaking down.
And it's starting
to really show up
as we increase the image size.
So you see as you
increase the resolution,
you get more clarity
in the image.
You're getting more
information for the most part.